ومشاهدينا وسط سيل المساعدات الغربيه
دائما ما تطالب كياف بامر اخر وهو تشديد
الخناق على روسيا اقتصاديا ولكن رغم توالي
حزم العقوبات وخاصه على صدرات النفط
الروسيه وجدت موسكو منفذا للالتفاف على
العقوبات عبر شركات احداها السويسريه ووسط
سعي مجموعه السبع لوضع سقف لاسعار النفط
الروسي تقوم شركه باراماوت بحسب او بارامت
بتسهيل تصدير النفطروسي هذه الشركه
السويسريه
تتمتع منذ فتره طويله بموضع قدم في ميناء
كوزمينو باقصى شرق روسي ومنه يتم تصدير
شحنه افطرسي الى عده موانئ صينيه بيانات
الشحن اظهرت ان باراموت باعت بانتظام شحنه
نفطن خام منذ عام 2020 الى منتصف العام
الماضي الا ان الحركه لم تتوقف كما اشار
تولد في تقرير لها الى ان شركه
مسؤوله عما يصل الى ربع اجمالي صادرات
النفط الخام من الميناء الروسي خلال الشهر
الماضي براموت اقرت بمشاركتها فقط 12
عمليه الشحن لنقل الخامه روسي قبل ان تحدد
مجموعه السبع الحد الاقصى للسعر ب 60
دولار وشددت على انها لم تنتهك العقوبات
على روسيا شحن نفطر مشاهدينا في الحالات
التي اعترفت بها باراماوت كان يتم
باستخدام سفن مسجله لشركه في الصين او
الهند او جزر مارشال وفقا لمعلومات المكتب
البحريه الدولي وبموجب العقوبات التي فرضت
في الخامس من ديسمبر الماضي يحذر على
الشركات او الافراد من دول منها امريكا
وبريطانيا وسويسرا والاتحاد الاوروبي
التجاره والسمسره او الشحن او التامين على
الخامه الروسي باي سعر يتجاوز 60 دولار